foreign of this game today 2-0 with the golden
knights both wins coming last year Capo kakinen
expected to go the distance for San Jose and
this one as we're underway in preseason game
number one of seven for the vgk we've got Jay
Theodore and Braden McNabb the most experienced
defense Bear for the golden knights they'll get
the start here in the preseason opener and up
front Brett Howden playing at Center on a line
with Paul Cotter and Max Coates drive for the
live score right off the bat Henry's run that
didn't take long 24 seconds after the opening
Face-Off I played as this Puck comes out High
a little key to Deep Run watch right in front
and zadina with the screen as he takes away
the eyes of Patera and a good shotgun head up
catch it past that first four Checker up high
the screen in front as the only goal so far
on the near side gushan hurdle trying
to center it Mayo got a piece of that
douching holds in the final five
seconds of the power play [Applause]
snap it down a hurdle feeds it across out
Heights run down to hurdle shot score it'll
be an even strength goal Jake ahead made his
way out of the box uh Tomah Turtle buries it
and it's two-nothing sharks as it moves around
watch the fake shot right there and then a pass
a beautiful plate a hurdle up top that sets up the
play and he just puts it under the glove of Patera
as hurdle gives the Sharks the tune-up along
with giersten krakno and dammit [Applause]
Smith digs it out along the wall Kirsten trying
to keep it alive in the puck back to neutral ice
and sent in by Nathan Todd now down the
wing Burrows feeds it across loose Puck
score Nathan Todd puts it home and all
San Jose in the opening 10 minutes foreign
and all alone in front is Nathan Todd just walks
in it's a centering feet Burrows that goes off
the skate right to Todd who comes in and goes
High over the right arm of Patera he said all
sharks praise to our field and Barbershop up front
now for he's just missed Pharmacy over the pass
here's Bishop across to Mayo he'll funnel in a
little further in front Barbers have a backhand
and he scores on a nice feed from dorofiev Ivan
Barbershop finds the back of the net in the golden
knights find the score boy keeps the puck in then
he goes over to male male just gets it down low
and there's Doro field what a heads up play by
him takes it Off the Wall little shoulder check
quick play to the front of that to Barbershop on
the backhand and he's able to elevate that pass
and thrown around the horn passed to
Hurdle from gooshen run again with
a look his shots gone that broke
through Patera Henry thrown over
the scoring in this period and he's
got another one in the final minute
his first press conference earlier the week about
the back to back champ during the parade back in
June he said you know look he he feels they have
a good chance to make another good run this year
he said you know every team's after the same
thing some teams are more reticent than others
to talk about it but their window was pretty
open right now when you look at what they did
last year the age of the team and the core of the
team right now oh and it's hard no question it is
and we've probably been in the hardest trophy
to win they need a lot of things to go right
it's a long 82-game regular season grind but
they certainly have pieces in place Rashad off
the bat here and a save made by pateros a good
look coming down the wing uh Southern Nevada
Toyota dealer's instant replay as zadina comes
down that left side lets the shot go to good
right arm blocker save pateri does a good job
anticipating that shot short side moves to that
Bishop around a male he'll feed it out back
into the Zone all towards the net door fee
for the backhand and Tack it in shuts it down
on the back Checker do Clary goes in and a big
save coconut in his Burrows snaps it down the
wing Patera I had to move that around the glass
I got blocked down trickles out High Lorac
with a shot blocked got hit demick gandorson
castles looking out top Drive got blocked down low
loose Gonna Save Me by Patera on Giovanni Smith
after the initial shot came from a hotel his
best of the game there's the shot from the
point Clinton gets blocked Gerson catches it
and Smith off to the side that puck comes he
can see Patera was moving to his left does
a good job the ship push off to the right
extends that block well two of the guys that's
really been noticed here for the goal line so
Barbershop the door Kiev in this game there's
friends walking in on a seat made by kakanin
good look for Byron phrase is in nine
games for the golden knights last year
they've got a goal and an
assist in that time frame
[__] sent in Deep by Robbins
they have tried to move that on second of Jacob
trying to move it around the wall get blocked down
person arbonoff able to pick that off needs an
across score Burrows after the person turnover
and it leads the goal for Kyle Burrows and
it's 5-1 San Jose this is no chance for Patera
he's gonna come up the wall here Hassan tries
to spin away get it out and it's good coverage
barbano keeps it then he slips past for a song
and then burles gets a step on Colton to come in
there's an offenseman of the Sharks pitches down
from the blue line on the floor jack works for
free to Benson set off out of the blue line here's
Mayo looking across Benson from a sharp angle and
yeah able to seal that off oh good look by mail
at the point as if benches take a second to settle
that puck off the pass hey the toddle started
out redlining in for him and off for a change
and Dish off at the wheel behind the Vegas net
here's Daniel chaker to the red line oh wired
around the Dasher dazzle's got pressured by
Howden out High chica his shot score that may
have been deflected Howden was in the top of
the crease there was some traffic on the way
to the net as Jacob let it fly from out High
to get the golden knights two within three speed
in is just Jacob rims it around watch Howden good
Pursuit on the puck gets body positioned good
little feed to the front Connor loses it and
then goes right back to the front of the net as
Jake Alexis goal bodies in front a shot through a
not sure how did howden's stick was right there
whether he got a stick line and Henry thrown the
defenseman or the Sharks plays it across Cotter
Zips it for brassonne set off out top Prasad his
shot see made by kakington he'll hold on setup's
going to take into the middle great little pass
back and this is brassonne where he likes to shoot
from on that off wing and half wall and that's a
quick release off his stick in a hurry but a good
save captain and he gets right up against that
hopefully he builds a little confidence too the
golanites have here in the final period of play
shots are 21-18 for the vgk is let's give
it away free t-shirts and hats here people
there's crackle off to Prasad his shot
in [Applause] decadentois gonna kick this
out and he drives that lane you can see Cotter
and person both High great beat by crackles he
finds person who lets it go and a trailing
to play but it's konto on the drives back
the defense that opens up the space for the
pass and sharks LED it from the beginning and
five to two win over the golden knights
in the preseason opener for both teams